yeah
both Avatar and Avatar the way of water
do something that from a screenwriting
perspective doesn't make any sense right
in the middle of the movie they both
stop all plot development and show a
long sequence wear at first glance it
seems like nothing important happens
characters spent a huge chunk of the
movie either flying or swimming around
no plot development no tension no Arc a
scene that could be completely cut
without affecting the story these scenes
are my favorite part of both movies but
James Cameron actually had to fight hard
to keep the flying sequence in the first
avatar according to Cameron the studio
exec said the scene went against basic
storytelling principles on how to Pace a
movie and they were complaining about
the flying scenes why does this flying
scene go on so long you've already
proved the point it doesn't Advance The
Narrative it doesn't Advance the
character I said you're right on every
count you've ticked every box like a
good Studio executive but if those
executives are right about the scene not
advancing The Narrative or the
characters why keep the long flying
scene in the first one and the even
longer underwater scene in the second
one and why does keeping them long work
so well to fully understand how the
studio executs got Avatar wrong let's
first talk about pacing one two three
next
people use the word pacing to describe
movies all the time there's fast-paced
movies which have lots of action or
quick-witted humor and then there's the
badly paced movies which is often just a
catch-all for a movie someone didn't
like especially if they found it slow or
boring Avatar clearly falls under the
fast-paced category with its frequent
and incredible action sequences which
makes a slower scene like the flying
sequence stand out that much more yet
for a word that's used so often pacing
is actually pretty difficult to Define
common definitions will say it's a movie
Speed how fast it unfolds but that's
just a word that means the same thing as
pace and speed doesn't explain what
makes a movie's pacing good or bad yet
the concept is crucial to making scenes
work and filmmakers regularly grapple
with the pace of their scenes there used
to be these beautiful drone shots of
Dave and Maddie riding on this
motorcycle then you put the scene
together and the scene's too long and
it's just well here are the gunshots see
him arrive pacing wise we also kind of
want to get to the island and get to the
mystery so whether you're doing drone
shots in Glass Onion or flying shots in
avatar the success of your scenes seems
to depend on this hard to Define idea of
pace so how do you nail it down the
answer lies in perhaps the fastest paced
movie of all time so let's get the party
started Meister
more rock and roll
the movie one two three moves at an
almost impossible speed and that's no
accident writer director Billy Wilder
wanted to make a comedy where the fast
pacing was itself a joke in his words
just the speed was funny I want you to
paint this Crest on the door of a car
how long will it take that's too long
but the speed of this movie doesn't just
come from Quick dialogue it's in the
framing the narrative and even just a
well-timed camera move bye bye Missy
wait a minute Phyllis there is a sort of
a misconception that pays and speaking
quickly is the same thing you can have
Pace by people not speaking quickly it
depends on the cut it depends on the
rhythm of the thing you want right of
inspection
I veto it I thought so throughout 123
James Cagney famously rattles off line
after line of impossibly complicated
orders to get Auto transformed into an
aristocrat ties not too wide not too
narrow not too fancy but you don't need
quick dialogue for a fast pace while the
stylists get Auto ready even more
characters enter the room making the
frame even busier Billy Wilder also
sticks to the master and avoids
close-ups giving our eye too much to
look at all at once and we end up with a
Renaissance painting on steroids it's
not just that the dialogue is fast or we
get huge camera movements it's the
combination of all the small movements
within the frame that makes it so busy
Billy Wilder also has the camera move
with the action even if it's subtle so
we can sense the movement without
necessarily noticing it what who's
paying for this foolishness 123 has the
conventional speed that we associate
with fast pace but sequences like these
also show why pacing isn't such a simple
concept to Define many of the scenes are
actually pretty long and they don't
always have fast dialogue or rapid
camera movements whether or not a scene
feels like it goes for too long depends
on more than just character dialogue or
camera speed it depends on harder to
generalize elements of the scene like
shot composition carefully choreographed
movement and editing yeah hell with the
Revolution and the hell with Russia
the hell with Frank Sinatra
so when Avatar Studio exec said the
flying scene went too long I think they
missed the point because the setup and
Technical execution of the flying
sequence actually makes it literally and
figuratively fly by in the scene Jake
Sully goes up to the Hallelujah
mountains to tame and fly his own
Mountain Banshee as part of his
initiation into the tribe at the very
start the scene uses contrast to create
a sense of scale we first see the effort
it takes to get to the top of these huge
mountains then Jake has to navigate a
small cramped Rock and finally he soars
through the mountains once difficult to
get through in the flying itself Cameron
alternates between wide flying shots and
close-ups capturing both the visual
spectacle and the moment's emotional
core this alternating Focus adds tension
like when we focus on Jake so we don't
see the obstacles until he does
oh
this buildup also leads to visual
payoffs when Jake gets the hang of
flying the camera finally slows down and
both Jake and the viewer earned the
incredible wide shots the scene is now
famous for shut up and fly straight
because this flying exists after those
high stakes and initial failures the
length of the sequence feels natural we
enjoy seeing Jake Master what once
almost killed him
Avatar n123 are completely different
movies yet they both create a fast pace
despite having long drawn out scenes
getting Auto prepared in one two three
happens in a single office with mostly
simple wide shots and the flag scene in
Avatar isn't very complicated compared
to the movie's other action scenes but
neither feels too long because they earn
their Simplicity Wilder creates fast
pace through character blocking and
subtle camera moves and Cameron creates
fast pace through tension and contrast
these long scenes in such fast-paced
movies expose the Paradox at the core of
pacing fast pacing isn't about going
fast it's about knowing when not to
in the book Empty moments Professor Leo
Charney talks about how movies often
present their narratives as a series of
emotional highs and lows which helps
create a sense of progression tension
and resolution this idea which charity
refers to as Peaks and valleys means
storytelling requires slower moments so
that the viewer can appreciate and
digest the fast ones and Billy Wilder
understood this concept All Too Well
when describing one two three he said
let's make the fastest picture in the
world and give the actors in order to
make it seem fast some slower scenes too
for every chaotic scene there is a
slower one like mac and Phyllis arguing
about their marriage or a long take of
slow dancing and slowness even happens
within the fast scenes themselves the
later dancing sequence may seem like
non-stop speed but it feels that much
more chaotic because of the contrast
within the scene itself its Peaks and
its valleys up until the flying scene in
Avatar all the movies World building has
created more Peaks than valleys For the
First Time The viewer doesn't have to
see or learn something new and like Jake
himself all that previous knowledge of
the world can finally sink in but
there's more to it than that the studio
execs seemed to only recall the flying
itself but in the seen supposed downtime
we also get setups for future payoffs
through the flying we see Jake's still
uneasy relationship with the rest of the
tribe and his growing relationship with
natiri we also fly past the Tree of
Souls and several animals on Pandora
that become crucial to the story later
on so the subtlety of pace means that
even within the valleys we get
productivity we can both enjoy the
downtime and also use that time to
better appreciate the future Peaks it's
from this idea of Peaks and valleys that
we can really understand what pacing
means it's the rhythm of a story like
rhythm in music storytelling as periods
of emphasis and periods of Silence of
Peaks and valleys film criticism
actually borrows a lot of words for
music to describe storytelling words
like Rhythm story beats or even a
crescendo because good stories naturally
have a sort of musical flow which leads
to a strange phenomenon lots of
well-paced movies not only have a strong
diegetic relationship with their musical
score but characters even perform the
score within the story itself once
you're on the lookout for this it shows
up everywhere in 123 Fraulein sings the
movie's main theme did
it and in Mad Max Fury Road this happens
and Avatar does the same thing the navi
move with the pulsing of the earth and
the score and that synchronicity between
the world and the score itself shows the
Superhuman relationship the navi have
with Pandora I'm not saying a movie with
a strong relationship with its score
automatically has better pacing what I
am saying is that if the score does
blend into the editing the pace or the
story itself then that means the movie
synchronized all its elements together
which tends to lead to well-paced movies
like one two three Whiplash and Avatar
and I think this idea shows what good
pacing really means good pacing is like
a well-designed roller coaster ride a
symphony of techniques with the Peaks
and valleys working together knowing
when to speed up and when to slow down
movies can start to feel slow right you
gotta play it just right well yeah
hopefully the idea is you're creating a
rhythm yeah and you're sailing on that
Rhythm and you're going with that Rhythm
and you can break up the rhythms and
everything but that's what's stopping it
from just being a talky drag
oh I'm sorry did I break your
concentration but if you ask James
Cameron why he kept the flying scene so
long he doesn't talk about creating
Rhythm and knowing how to handle it in
fact he mentions a director who rejected
the idea entirely you've ticked every
box like a good Studio executive but
guess what I want to see it and I
extrapolate from that and Stanley
Kubrick was a firm proponent of this
principle if I want to see it my
cognitive leap is there are going to be
lots of people that want to see it
does the concept of Peaks and valleys
even apply to a director like Stanley
Kubrick consider his 1987 film Full
Metal Jacket the first 45 minutes take
place at boot camp before soldiers ship
off to Vietnam and the two main
characters Private Pyle and drill
sergeant Hartman don't even show up in
the rest of the movie It's essentially a
separate short film as a studio exec
might point out the story and characters
don't impact the plot of the rest of the
movie It's Peaks and valleys for an
unrelated story and Stanley Kubrick
makes these unconventional pacing
choices all the time the how subplot in
2001 A Space Odyssey is another short
film within a film and that movie along
with most of Kubrick's catalog has a lot
more valleys than Peaks it's clear that
in his movies Kubrick didn't prioritize
pacing or Rhythm on the contrary he has
no issue with disjointed elongated
movies like The Flying scene in Avatar
he doesn't care if scenes are out of
context or go for too long and that
choice helps us feel like his characters
whose repetition also leads them to
their slow descent into madness best
characterized by the famous Kubrick
stare
but how far can a director go to be
honest I'm not always entirely sure how
I feel about Kubrick's famously slow
pace Full Metal Jacket has an incredible
short film within a film but the rest of
the movie does meander quite a bit is
that creative Choice a clever symbol for
the meaninglessness of the Vietnam War
itself or does the choice hurt the story
by making it too unfocused that answer
like pacing itself is impossible to
fully resolve but that's the beauty of
Kubrick or Cameron's movies no matter
how I feel about them during a re-watch
I'm forever grateful that I got to see
what the director wanted to see not what
some studio exec thought an audience
would want
pacing definitely matters especially
when a moment feels too rushed or a
scene drags out longer than it should
but I also think relying on pacing to
explain a movie risks reducing
storytelling to its purpose if a
filmmaker's primary concern is pacing
then every moment must exist for some
objective reason instead of because it's
part of the filmmaker's vision so for
directors like Stanley Kubrick and James
Cameron good pacing is a requirement
that is not only too restrictive but it
also doesn't matter or at least they
don't worry about it and for great
directors the problem seems to sort
itself out and James Cameron has
definitely doubled down on this idea in
avatar The Way of water not only is the
water sequence much longer than the
flying sequence in Avatar 1 but it has
even less of the conventional narrative
or character advancement they can't even
talk when you're underwater there's no
dialogue there may be nothing else but
the music to tell you how to feel
characters who are conflicted about what
they should do next but they can't go oh
what do I do because they're underwater
so the music has to do that
the purpose is to be present to be in
that world to be enjoying what's
happening to sustain a feeling so those
flying scenes actually did have a big
purpose that's when Jake and natiri fell
in love and I got into a big fight with
the studio one of the things I was
thinking when I was watching Avatar was
wanting to Kill Bill I had these
grandiose Visions in my head of the
experience of watching the movie and I
actually wanted it to be more like a
ride I don't think I did that and when I
saw it that's the ride that's the ride I
was trying to do
[Music]
the flying scene in Avatar 1 and the
underwater scene in Avatar 2 show
Cameron's Mastery over his production
the combination of score
characterization and special effects to
create the ultimate ride and these
scenes didn't come to fruition because
of some application of the textbook
definition of pacing it may not sound
intuitive at first but directors like
Cameron and Kubrick don't really care
about pacing they care about what they
want to see and that itself creates a
purpose it doesn't always matter if that
purpose goes against conventional Peaks
and valleys Studio XX got Avatar wrong
because they worked in the wrong
direction purpose comes from what you
want not some screenwriting book or some
pretentious video essay on pacing that
tells you what to do so good pacing
isn't just about speed or action it's
about creating tension balancing
spectacle with emotional resonance and
earning the big payoffs through
well-crafted setups but when filmmakers
get it right even scenes that go against
conventional wisdom can turn into the
most memorable and most impactful
moments in a movie so when you watch a
story unfold or write your own remember
that it doesn't have to check all the
boxes of what makes a story well paced
instead think like James Cameron because
I want to see it now you see it
[Music]